hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe i'm your host john
carroll
we are here for the q a video for idea
number 19 which is probability and
randomness
but first elephant in the room the real
news here is
haircut has happened for the first time
in the pandemic real
professional haircut not a personal
haircut
we had someone friend of ours come over
actually to our house
wore masks and everything very very
responsible but now
okay hair's looking more normal a little
bit less scraggly
you know i have mixed feelings about
this i kind of liked the uh scraggly
academic look but
you know there's something to be said
for gravitas and professionalism also
um of course the last rather than next
to regular videos in the big ideas
series
were already recorded before the haircut
happened so right now you get to see the
haircut but the next two videos i'm as
scraggly as ever
sorry about that um so today we're
supposed to be here for the probability
and randomness q
a video but to be honest there weren't a
lot of questions
about probability and randomness there
were questions of course there are
always questions
lots of people like to ask questions
about lots of things
if you ever do want to ask questions
about things that are not about these
videos
the trick is to become a patreon
supporter of the mindscape podcast and
then you get to ask questions at the
monthly ask me anything and then i will
do my best
to answer every single question but here
i like to try to keep the questions
about the topic of the video
and really there are almost no questions
about the actual subject of probability
and randomness so
there's going to be a short video today
what i'm going to do is take advantage
of that extra time
i'm going to make an extra little bonus
video which is not about physics at all
but about how i make these videos i
already did a little bit of an
explanation for that
um that was buried in the q a video for
force
and and energy in action and so no one
sees it if they don't watch
every single video so a lot of people
have emailed me asking you know what is
the technology the software or whatever
so i'm going to make another video about
that and post that separately that's
what i'll do with the extra time for
this
shortened uh video today but there were
a lot of questions about but you know i
don't have a lot to say about was
norton's dome
okay so we do want to talk a little bit
about norton's dome
and norton's dome was supposed to be an
example of how
classical newtonian mechanics can fail
to be perfectly deterministic
for initial conditions that are set at
measure zero so they're there
but they're infinitely finely tuned and
the idea was you had a dome
i'm not going to draw the dome very well
but you could sit a ball on top of the
dome
and then it could roll down and if the
height of the dome was a very specific
uh form r to the three halves
height is measured sort of downward and
r by the way i mistook i said that r was
the just the radial distance
uh and sort of in the plane but r is
actually this distance
on the dome okay tiny little difference
it doesn't really make
much of a difference but just if you try
to get things right okay
and so the point was you can solve this
of course there's a solution where the
ball is sitting right at the top of the
dome
and never ever moves but there are also
solutions where the ball can sit at the
top of the dome
for arbitrarily long periods of time for
literally any period of time
and then start rolling okay and so the
time at which it starts rolling
is not determined by the initial
conditions the initial conditions are
simply
the ball is sitting stationary at the
top of the dome
it can stay as long as it wants or it
can roll at any time so norton actually
first introduced this
as a way to question whether or not
causality
is a perfectly good concept well defined
in newtonian mechanics
we're not really about that today it's
more about the determinism aspect that
we were interested in
but you know it turns out i didn't
really get into this very much uh
in my researches i knew about norton's
dome but i didn't want to make a big
deal of it i just wanted to give it as a
cute little example
uh and in part to compare with quantum
mechanics
but people get very emotional it turns
out about norton's dome
people don't like the idea that
classical mechanics might not be
perfectly deterministic or at least that
this is a counter example
um so let me just i have very little to
say about that you know i don't get
emotional about this uh myself it's you
know just
it's not for one thing classical
mechanics is not the real world right
if you're a mathematician and you want
to solve you know you want to understand
the space of solutions to different
differential equations then by all means
i understand
why you should care about this but if
you're a physicist
yeah classical mechanics has its
properties but they're not real so who
cares in some sense i mean it's it's
good to know what the properties are
here the answer is there's a set of
measure zero
you know infinitely unlikely to be
chosen randomly in the set of all
possible initial conditions
that do not seem to be deterministic so
let me just explain a little bit more
about what's going on here if you
if you solve that the point is you're
solving newton's equation of motion
f equals m a which is m
dv dt right where v is the velocity
which is m d squared x dt squared
or you can rather than x you can choose
r okay
so the point is that the force
needs to be zero even when the ball
starts moving and how can that be true
why would the ball start moving if the
force is zero when you're sitting at the
top of the dome
you're sitting up here there's no net
force acting on you there's a
gravitational force pushing you down
but the dome has a responding force that
is pushing you up in exactly
enough way to compensate so there's zero
force on you
so naively you look at this equation and
you say well there's no force on you
there's no acceleration you don't start
moving
but what norton did is he carefully
chose the shape of his dome
so that uh there's a solution that looks
like
r is proportional to t
oops t minus t naught to the power of
four okay so what does that mean so
the point is the reason why he chose
this r equals three halves up here
is that when you get the solution to
figure you know you differentiate
the potential energy to get the force
plug it into this equation and so forth
then you find that this is indeed a
solution for
any value of t naught that's the point
okay
and what's going on here is if you plot
so here is r as a function of t okay
and we'll just use different colors to
make it very clear so
the solution is oh actually sorry what i
should say is let me uh
be a little bit more clear here um
yeah let me let me be more clear here so
let me just erase this
the equation is right but i need to say
something else the point is that
there's a solution where r equals this
oops for
times after
t naught and r just equals zero for
times
before t naught in fact equal to because
it's the same
at t naught okay so that's the point
that is the what makes this all
special if we plot r versus t
then our solution looks like let's take
t naught equals zero
just to be very very simple about it um
in fact let's make our
pen a little thicker so it's easier to
see and so the solution looks like this
r is just zero and then at t naught it
starts moving like this
okay so to see why this is possible
think about you know forget just that t
naught equals zero like we just said
right so r is proportional to t to the
fourth
the velocity which is the derivative of
r
respect to time goes like t cubed uh
therefore the acceleration goes like t
squared and again this is all
t greater than or equal to t naught
which equals zero
here okay everything is zero before t
naught before zero and then everything
becomes these curves so then the jerk
remember the jerk is a d-a-d-t
which goes like t and the snap
which goes like the second derivative of
a with respect to time
goes like a constant
so everything is very smooth and matches
on very very nicely at t equals zero
but something does happen but something
dramatic doesn't really happen
until the snap which is the second
derivative of acceleration or if you
like
the fourth derivative of the position
with respect to time okay so to make
this
clear we could plot all these little
buggers um
let's plot the velocity okay well
velocity is going
it's going to look very similar to be
honest um i cannot draw sufficiently
carefully enough that you can
tell the difference between t to the
fourth and t cubed in my drawing
likewise guess what um that's the
velocity
here's the acceleration it's going to
look pretty much the same now it's t
squared okay
these are all really different this is t
to the fourth t cubed t
squared the jerk goes linearly in t and
now we see
now begin to see what is going on so the
jerk
come on oops white
the jerk as a function of time is going
to be
constant namely zero before t and then
it's linear
and the snap
is going to be discontinuous so the snap
goes like
this constant and then boom
and all this is just from taking
derivatives of the initial function
and you might say well okay that's
what's going weird here your snap
your fourth derivative with respect to
time suddenly was discontinuous
at t equals zero and what that means is
you know i should have said this before
but
um if you just went up here and solved
newton's equation
f equals m a this is norton's original
point if this is all you're doing
you say i give you the position i give
you the velocity
initially i give you the force the
potential energy function that you can
differentiate to get the force
and then i solve it right so this is a
solution but for any value of t naught
it's a solution so there's another
solution that looks like this where it's
constant to some other time
and then starts going as t to the fourth
and there's another
solution where it started going earlier
right
all of these are perfectly good
solutions so
the actual solution is not picked by the
initial conditions
and then you would likewise shift all of
these guys so if you look
in the literature see what people say
about this there is a tradition that
says
well okay you've obviously cheated
because
the correct physical allowed solutions
are those for which
all the derivatives are perfectly
continuous
so because the fourth derivative the
snap is not continuous this is a fake
solution this is not really good
and norton you know i think quite
correctly says wait a minute wait a
minute
you didn't say anything when you gave me
the rules of the game
about infinite continuity for all of the
derivatives okay you just
made up a new rule and are you allowed
to make up a new rule well you know
maybe sure why not go make up all the
rules you want um
but you don't have to make up that rule
you could just say like you
stuck with the rules that newton wrote
down right and in that case it's not
deterministic but
again uh my point was not actually to
pick out you know just to sort of make
fun
of newtonian mechanics because nutonian
mechanics is not
right if instead you have quantum
mechanics
h psi equals i times the time derivative
of psi this does not have
any of that lack of determinism okay
there's no
even set of measure zero initial data
for which this
simple first order time derivative
equation
doesn't have solutions now quantum
mechanics has other issues
with indeterminacy as we know as we've
talked about
but that is a difference and classical
mechanics is not right it's just
supposed to be an approximation to
quantum mechanics so
if your interest is in you know again
mathematically
the behavior of different sets of
equations then by all means get worked
up
about newton nordenstone but if your
interest is in
is the universe deterministic or not
norton's dome says nothing about that
because it's about classical mechanics
it's not about quantum mechanics which
is the real world as far as we know
um furthermore i should say that
norton's dome is not the only example
of non-determinism in newtonian
mechanics uh some people like to use the
following example i don't like it but
i'll
tell you what it is you have three
particles that just come
and they collide okay
three particles newtonian mechanics
and they collide exactly at a point and
well the point is that you know they
have momentum they have energy that's
conserved and
they can scatter off of each other at a
large number of different angles and
still
conserve all the energy conserve all the
momentum obey newton's equations
um it's also clearly a set of initial
conditions that are of measure zero
because they're literally point
particles they're not little billiard
balls then it would be a different thing
they're
literally points so they have to exactly
hit each other at the same time for this
to make sense um
that just seems like horribly singular
to me the forces when they hit each
other are infinite
right so i think in this case it's safe
to say this is just not really
well-defined
but if you want to say it's
non-deterministic that's also good
that's also okay with me there's another
example which
i hesitated when i was thinking about
the original
idea video i was going to talk about
this but then i really
did not understand it myself and so i
didn't talk about it um
now that i'm doing the q a i still do
not understand it
but i figured i can just admit that i do
not understand it i can tell you about
it if you want to read about it
and that is the famous space invaders
counter example oops invaders
so the idea here is um you have
space and time okay x t
there you go and you're doing newtonian
mechanics with gravity
okay so there's a bunch of particles
that exert
inverse square law forces on each other
and there's a bunch of them it's not
just two or three there's like i think
you need five or eight or something like
that
and so you have a bunch of particles you
know at some initial time and they're
all doing crazy
things you know they're interacting with
each other blah blah blah and
the claim is and again i find this claim
hard to believe
but it's a claim that's that someone
makes and they're mathematically careful
so probably there's something
i just don't understand about it but the
claim is you can arrange these initial
conditions
very very carefully so that one of these
particles interacts and it zooms off
after these interactions or you know the
interactions never really end because
it's a one over r squared law so there's
always some
force being exerted the one of these
particles has the property
that it goes to x equals infinity before
some specific time t star
okay so there's a time that this
newtonian
particle acting under the force of
gravity interacting with all of its
friends
never reaches it goes infinitely far
away
infinitely fast remember newtonian
mechanics not special relativity there's
no speed of light
rule here okay so this one particle can
just zoom
off as fast infinitely fast really and
not reach the future and then just like
with norton's dome we can do the
following thing
we can take this picture let's see if i
can do this it's always an adventure
when i cut and paste in uh
notability and uh i can turn it upside
down
now i can relabel okay so
just move the arrows point them the
other way
uh x and t and what i have now
is oops my t is upside down here so
now the point is again it's still
newtonian gravity and there's some time
t star before which there's a certain
number of particles
and then at t star a particle zooms in
from infinitely far away to join the
particles that are already there
okay that's why it's called space
invaders because this particle here
i should have made a different color but
this particle here is zooming in
from spatial infinity to join the others
and that particle was not there before
t star so you could not have predicted
its existence
by just giving me the initial data at
any time before t star
now again i do not understand exactly
the details of the proof that this is
possible
but people who have looked at it claim
to say that it's okay so it seems okay
so this is a different kind of failure
of determinism but it is a failure of
determinism the failure here is saying
that
i don't know whether or not stuff is
coming in from infinitely far away
at arbitrary times now again newtonian
mechanics is not right so maybe you
shouldn't be bothered by this but
certainly you shouldn't be too
emotionally attached to showing that
newtonian mechanics is deterministic
let's let's put it that way so there are
different examples about how newtonian
mechanics is not completely
deterministic now
the other thing people said was well and
i
i'm sure that i mentioned this in the
video but people said it anyway
you cannot possibly actually arrange
the initial conditions in norton's dome
so exactly that it will literally sit
there for an arbitrary long period of
time and then start rolling
either because of quantum mechanics or
just because of in
in precision in how you place the
particle there initially or
because there's no such thing as a
closed system and there will be you know
cosmic rays or air molecules or
just photons buffeting the particle
so i mean you know the answer to that is
duh
you know obviously not and this has to
do
with uh the bigger issue which is worth
getting into of laplace's demon
plus demon says that if you knew
everything you could predict what's
going to be in the future
and norton's dome and the space invaders
are both examples of how
if you just take your rules to be
classical mechanics as newton wrote them
down laplace's demon doesn't quite work
but maybe you could patch it up so that
it works that's fine
but there was this idea that laplace's
demon is undermined by chaos theory
so chaos theory is worth explaining i i
did mention this but let me say again
what it is chaos theory is the idea that
under
certain conditions for for certain
physical systems
small variations in initial conditions
lead to large
variations
in final conditions
now that i'm thinking about it i'm
writing it down i realized it's possible
i didn't actually say this
in the probability video but i will say
it in upcoming video
there's a problem with doing the videos
before you know weeks in advance
um so this sounds like a very
loosey-goosey statement what do you mean
by small what do you mean by large but
it's been made very very precise it
means that
uh the variations in the final
conditions
depend exponentially on variations in
the initial conditions okay they did not
depend
linearly or even quadratically or
something like that
so that's a literal quantitative way of
making sense of the idea that
any tiny variation in the initial
conditions makes your system
unpredictable if you don't know exactly
what the initial conditions are
and so this you know was a big deal when
it was invented
different people sort of came into the
idea of chaos theory from different
directions
poncare who we've met before was one of
the people he was trying to actually
there's a long fascinating story about
poncare
proving that the solar system was
completely stable and he wrote a paper
you know this was like a challenge like
what they used to do back in the day was
like the king of sweden
would announce a contest for the best
mathematical essay and then you know the
great minds of
europe would write their mathematical
essays and it will be judged by
somebody and the king would give you a
prize i don't think that happens anymore
but we have other ways of uh
rewarding good ideas so poncare wrote
his essay and it won the prize
and uh they were publishing it and you
know as happens
uh you go and the editors read your
publication and they give you notes and
you
try to correct it and somewhere in the
process of refereeing or editing
someone pointed out you know there was a
mistake there was a gap
in the proof that poincare had and
pancreate was a smart guy he
looked at the comment he realized it was
correct and he set out to fix it and he
ended up proving the opposite
that approving the solar system is not
stable and this more or less uh can
it can be thought of as the origin of
chaos theory uh in some sense there are
other people like lorentz
different lorenz not hour lorentz had
ideas that led to
this kind of unpredictability and so
people have said
that this idea of chaos theory
undermines laplace's demon
okay so forget about niceties of measure
zero
like norton's dome or space invaders or
whatever
chaos theory is just saying for generic
initial conditions
for any initial conditions if your
system is chaotic some systems are
chaotic some systems are not
it's easy simple systems can be chaotic
you don't have to work very hard to make
a system chaotic
for generic initial conditions for a
chaotic system
if you don't know exactly the
initial conditions and by the way you
never do
know exactly the initial conditions then
you cannot predict what will happen in
the future and therefore
the argument goes laplace's demon is
somehow undermined
okay i've always thought and continue to
think this is completely nonsensical
argument i mean it's a bunch of true
statements but it completely misses the
point
um chaos theory you know laplacian demon
says
if i know the initial conditions exactly
i can
tell you what's going to happen next
chaos theory says if i don't know the
initial conditions exactly i cannot tell
you even approximately what will happen
next
those two statements are not
contradictory there's statements about
different initial assumptions whether
you know the conditions exactly or not
and people try to say well yes but the
point is you never know the conditions
exactly
to which again i will say duh everyone
knows that that was
laplace's demon was never supposed to be
a research program it was never supposed
to be like let's build
something that would be laplace's demon
it's not
really a statement about a vast
intelligence who should be able to know
things and predict things
it's a statement about the structure of
the theory it's distinguishing between
a theory that is deterministic from
which the initial conditions predict
the future and other theories that are
not deterministic right there are plenty
of theories
where you just can't even in principle
predict the future from arbitrarily
accurate initial conditions and that's
the point of laplace's demon
not that you could ever build it and so
chaos theory introduces a
practical limitation on how close you
can get to being laplace's demon
but even without chaos theory even if
you just take like a box of gas with
things bumping into each other
uh you can't come very close being
laplace's demon because the world
has too many moving parts in it it was
never supposed to be a practical
kind of thing so i never i mean chaos
theory is intrinsically interesting
in and of itself but it's not its
interest is not because it overthrows
the idea of laplace's demon in in any
way
um and likewise for you know quantum
fluctuations etc
okay two more uh questions or topics
came up
one was uh determinism
which we were talking about uh versus
free will
and i don't have a lot to say about this
because i do have a lot to say about
this topic in general
read my book you know read the big
picture or read janae ismael's book uh
how physics makes us free
or listen to the various podcasts i've
done on this but i just want to make one
very brief
point about this relationship here you
know the issue is
if we thought that we did live in a
deterministic universe
if we thought that the laws of physics
were classical
and laplace's demon was correct and we
put aside sets of measure zero
and we put aside chaos theory and all
that stuff
then how in the world can you think that
human beings
have the ability to freely choose what
to do next human beings are made of
stuff that stuff obeys the laws of
physics
laws of physics are deterministic full
stop that's all you have
okay now so some people say that their
the the choice is between determinism
and free will where free will is
interpreted as the ability to make
choices individual human autonomous
choices okay
the only point i want to make here is
that that is not the choice
there's no relationship between whether
the world is deterministic or not and
whether or not you have
free will or not okay the world can be
deterministic
and you have free will or it can be
deterministic and you don't have free
will or it can be non-deterministic and
you have free will or non-deterministic
and you don't ever will all those
are absolutely legitimate intellectual
positions so when i say
the world can be what i mean is there
are smart people
who believe the world is like that okay
i mean obviously the world is one way or
the other
uh but there's no in principle
incompatibility between determinism and
free will nor
more importantly is there some idea that
if the world were
non-deterministic that would somehow
help you have free will
okay so let's be very clear about what i
mean the
if you're deterministic then the
question is what do you mean by free
will
and guess what people don't agree on
what they mean by free will and this is
quickly where it becomes the world's
most boring argument to have because i
don't care what definition
you use the interesting question is what
not how you define
free will but how you deal with the fact
that
on the one hand the world is
microscopically deterministic
if it were let's imagine that it were
okay the world is made of things
atoms and so forth that obey laws of
physics and you don't have control over
them
um but you don't know what the
conditions of those atoms are you don't
know you're not laplace's demon okay you
don't know what the
position of velocity of every single
particle in your body is
so what attitude should you take
and there's two attitudes you can take
one attitude is what i care about
is the in principle question could i
sort of violate the laws of physics by
my human volition and if i can't
then i say don't have free will the
other point of view you can take is
look i would like to describe real human
beings
using the actual knowledge those human
beings have because what i care about is
coming up with the best effective theory
that i can
if you hearken back to the days we're
doing effective field theories right
i'm not doing the complete ultraviolet
completion of the world i'm doing an
effective theory of human action
and human beings don't know positions
and velocities of all those particles so
who cares about the in-principle
determinism underneath
what i want to do is describe people as
they are with the information
they have and it may very well turn out
that the best way to do that is to
imagine that those people
are described as choice making agents
right as people who are able to take
information think about it make choices
on the basis of that
that is called compatibilism
compatibilism between determinism
and free choice or volition or free will
or whatever you want to call it okay
personally as someone who believes in
you know emergence and higher levels
different ways of talking about the
universe i find the compatibilist point
of view
very compelling i think you know it
makes sense i don't know
anyone who denies free will
who really goes all the way to saying
you know
never mentioning the idea that human
beings make choices
okay whether human beings should choose
one thing or the other
of course they say all the time that
human beings make choices
and they say yes but i don't really mean
it you know what i really mean is that
there's something going on underneath if
you say the human beings make choices
and you really mean it
and you also believe that the laws of
physics underlying everything are
perfectly deterministic and you can't
violate them
there's a word for what you are it's
called compatibilist
that's what you are that's what
compatibilists do
and so there's no in principle
incompatibility
in the space of all possible positions
one can stake out
between determinism and free will but
more
importantly i realize i'm not drawing
anything i don't really have anything to
draw here's a person
okay and they're thinking about things
they're making choices
there you go that's the best i can do to
draw something the much more important
point i want to make is
what if the laws of physics were not
deterministic okay
um what if it was grw theory remember we
talked about all the different
possible um formulations of quantum
mechanics one of them are these
spontaneous collapse theories
where truly unpredictably the wave
function of the universe
just collapses onto locations of certain
particles
at some rate of probability per unit
time etc okay
so that's a theory that's a whole family
of theories
which is truly not deterministic okay
you cannot predict the future from the
past
because there's an element of randomness
in the fundamental equations
does that give you free will no of
course not
why would that give you free will
there's some random possibility that an
electron collapses at
its wave function therefore i can choose
no that just doesn't follow at all
if you are not a compatibilist okay if
you're
not willing to say that i'm going to
describe human beings at a higher level
of emergent behavior with incomplete
information if you're just
a hardcore microscopic describer of
things okay
whether or not the underlying laws of
physics are deterministic or not
has absolutely zero to do with whether
or not you believe in free will
what it has to do with is are there laws
right
if there are laws that human beings obey
that are microscopic and reductionist
and you want to be the kind of person
who says that excludes the possibility
of free will
whether those laws are deterministic or
not is completely
irrelevant the question is do the human
beings obey
the laws right if that's going to be
your attitude so
again determinism is not the thing
that is opposed to free will you can be
deterministic or not deterministic
you can believe in free will or not and
all four of the little
uh boxes in that grid can be filled up
so
that's all i want to say about free will
i'm not going to tell you which box you
should be in but all the boxes exist
okay that's all i want
uh you to believe final question is
um and this is i have very little to say
about this one
uh bayesianism
which we did talk about bayesian
ism bayesianism so there's bases rule or
bases law or basis theorem whatever you
want to call it there's an equation
okay the probability of the theory
theory ti given the data is the
probability of
the data in that theory the likelihood
function
times the prior probability of that
theory divided by the total probability
of getting that data
over all different possible theories
okay this is the
equation you use for updating your
priors that's your prior
to get your posterior probability given
the data
your prior probability that theory i is
correct versus after you have the data
so this is this is bayes's rule and it's
just true this is just an equation in
fact look
i can multiply both sides and what you
find is that
the probability of the theory given the
data times the probability of the data
equals the probability of the data given
the theory
times the probability of the theory and
this in fact is just a mathematical
identity
that's why based not have to work very
hard to prove his theorem once you
understand
what the definition of a conditional
probability is this is going to become
very clear
so the point is that this is not
bayesianism
yet this is just a theorem in
probability just a mathematical theorem
bayesianism
is kind of a philosophy of life
uh it's the philosophy that you should
think about all probabilities
in this way and there's objective
bayesianism which i just don't
understand
and subject to bayesianism which says
i'm going to invent my priors there
might be
smarter or less smart ways to invent
them but still i invent them
the motto is you know everyone is
welcome to their own
priors but not to their own likelihoods
okay
the likelihood function should be
predicted by your theory and then you
know
you go through life updating your priors
when new data comes in that's the
philosophy of bayesianism
but this is true you know this these
equations are true for
anyone's philosophy of probability
there's mathematical theorems
and the question i want to get to was
bayesianism versus although not really
verses
i mean compared to quantum bayesianism
so you may have heard of this i forget
whether
we've actually mentioned it
um quantum bayesianism is one of the
approaches to what we called
epistemic uh philosophies of quantum
mechanics
so in the epistemic approach to quantum
mechanics the wave function
okay psi of x remember so psi
as we do it in dirac notation capital
psi let's make it
um there's an element of hilbert space
right and if you were a many worlds
person
you say that's the world that is the
complete description of reality this
wave function in hilbert space
you can represent it as a square
integrable complex valued function over
the space of all configurations or
something like that but who cares it's a
vector in helper space and that's
reality
the quantum bayesian says this is
not reality at all what this is what the
wave function is is a way of making
predictions
about observational outcomes so the
ontologies of philosophers would say
if you're an evoredian is a vector in
hilbert space that's what reality is
um if you're a quantum bayesian then
the ontology is there are agents
and agents have experiences and there's
a rule
for figuring out how you're going to
predict the probability of having
different experiences by starting with
your wave function the wave function to
a quantum bayesian
is analogous to the priors in regular
old classical bayesianism
the wave function might be different for
two different people the wave function
of an electron a single electron
might be different in the minds of two
different people because the wave
function is a fundamentally subjective
thing
to a quantum bayesian and then it's um
some admixture of the rules of quantum
mechanics for
changing wave functions and the rules of
bayesian probability theory
so if you but if you say to a quantum
bayesian okay but if the wave function
isn't reality
what is reality
i have i have trouble understanding
their answers uh
they don't ever quite tell you what the
answer is what they will say is that
reality uh comes into existence through
the mutual
experiences of all the agents it still
doesn't tell you what it is
right i've not quite gotten an answer as
to what the the
reality is maybe quantum bayesian will
will chime in
but the the question was you know or at
least my reading of the question
that i saw on youtube or wherever it was
was you know how do these things relate
to each other if you're a good
bayesian does that imply or suggest that
maybe you should be a good quantum
bayesian
um so no you know i think that uh
quantum bayesianism is
an ambitious it's still you know let's
be fair to the theory i have
i have no special interest in quantum
bayesianism it's just not my
deal at all i'm a realist um all these
epistemic approaches
are kind of instrumental they're using
quantum mechanics to make predictions
rather than directly describing reality
i think that the way to make progress is
to try to directly describe reality and
people have tried
to mix epistemic approaches saying that
the formalism of quantum mechanics
is about making predictions with realist
ontology
so you say well making predictions about
what um and that
that attempt has completely failed as
far as i know no one actually has a
working theory where quantum mechanics
is all about
knowledge and probabilities and reality
is about something different
okay so i like the idea that quantum
mechanics is just about reality full
stop
having said that quantum basianism is
relatively
new right relatively youthful as
theories go
there's a lot of smart people who put a
lot of credence in it as it were have
high priors that
it is true or high posteriors um and so
i'm very happy that they're working on
it and you know maybe it will lead to
some
kind of breakthrough you know you have
to pick your battles when you're doing
research in physics
um and maybe this is a good uh place to
stop because i'm done
talking about quantum basianism but this
is a good big philosophy point to end
the q a video on um
you know look i remember being shocked
when i was in grad school
because i was in grad school late 80s
early 90s this was after the first
superstring revolution which was in 1984
uh so certain people uh just fell in
love with string theory they thought the
super strength theory was the way
forward clearly was gonna be the theory
of everything soon predicting the mass
of the electron et cetera you know
it was it was great um other people were
incredibly skeptical
so uh i was a grad student at harvard i
was in the astronomy department
but in the physics department you know
we had one young assistant professor
doing string theory but none of the
senior faculty did string theory whereas
other places like
um princeton you know were all string
theory and
the number of major university
departments that were dominated by
string theory was
small at the time it wasn't very big it
wasn't until
the second super string revolution that
suddenly everywhere
had to have string theorists right um
now but the point is i was going to get
to was that so circa 19 you know 92 or
whatever before the second super string
revolution i was still a grad student we
had a visitor
come to give a talk and he gave a talk
on you know certain dark matter
candidates
in super string theory and i said well
you know i i
asked him some question that that was in
a related context that was not super
string theory and he said look
i don't care my idea is to work on
string theory and i'm just not
interested
in ideas that are not in the context of
string theory and at the time
i was kind of outraged by this i was
like oh come on like you know
how do you know that string theory is
right like maybe it's right but it could
be wrong
um now that i'm older and wiser and much
more sympathetic even though my chance
that string theory is right has not
really changed
one way or the other in the last 25
years or whatever
but the idea that you need to make a
choice
is something that i now understand
better a choice of what to work on so
you may very well think that the
theory you're working on has an 80
chance of being true
and a 20 chance of being false but
nevertheless
you choose to put a hundred percent of
your effort into working
on that theory in fact you may only
think that the theory you're working on
has a 10
chance of being true and a 90 chance of
being false
but you're saying look no one else is
working on this theory
i think this theory has a 10 chance if
i'm right
it's hugely important i'm going to
ignore everything else and work on this
theory okay
and my point is that's a completely
rational strategy
to adopt uh because you you
you don't have to spread your
individual research or intellectual
effort equally over all the different
theories in the world
the field should do that science as a
whole should do that we should have
people working on one theory people
working on another theory as long as
we're not sure which one
is correct but not every individual has
to do that that would be horribly
inefficient
right you have some people who bet one
way and some people who bet the other
way
and so when it comes to quantum
mechanics and the foundations of quantum
mechanics
there's a sense in which i do research
in the foundations of quantum mechanics
right i clearly do i write papers on it
etc
but the community of people working in
foundations of quantum mechanics
get together and have all these meetings
where they talk about all these
different formulations of quantum
mechanics right you know bayesianism and
uh grw theory and bowman mechanics and
they prove all these theorems and
etcetera etcetera
and i just doesn't interest me because
my
take on the foundations of quantum
mechanics is that
everett is probably right in my mind and
what i want to spend my time doing
is pushing that theory forward
understanding how that theory fits
into what we know about the world and
that is
so when i so i'm just not that
interested
in people doing work in quantum
basianism okay but not because i think
that they're wrong
i think they're probably wrong but they
could be right and i'm glad they're
doing it
i just don't want to do it myself and i
think that's a perfectly valid way
of having you know intellectual effort
be spread throughout the world different
people should work on different things
they should be you know happy with their
paradigms in which they're working
trying to drive them forward
and if they turn out to be wrong they
should change their minds but until they
turn out to be wrong until we know that
they're wrong
sticking with what they're doing makes
perfect sense and that's what we're
doing that's what i'm doing
i hope we all make progress doing these
things